[Music]
foreign
briefing for Wednesday February 15th I'm
Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
two years ago bite dance the parent
company of tick tock bought a Chinese
startup called Pico that makes virtual
reality headsets in that short period
even though Pico doesn't sell its
consumer headsets in the US it became
the second best-selling VR headset
globally according to Industry data the
market for VR headsets is small but
growing the market value is estimated to
be worth around 4 billion dollars in
2022 and in the third quarter of last
year alone more than a million headsets
were shipped bite dances growth puts it
on the heels of meta in the VR space
meta the parent company of Facebook and
Instagram is already battling bite dance
and Tick Tock for users and AD dollars
in the social media space with me to
discuss this new front in the battle
between these Tech Giants is our
reporter Megan boborowski Hi Megan
always great to have you on the show
thanks Zoe So Megan you spoke with some
of the people who've been using Pico
headsets what have they said about it me
and my colleague spoke to someone in the
UK who bought the new Pico headset and
liked so much that they sold their
metaquest to on eBay three weeks later
and then I also spoke to someone in
Canada who ordered it from Spain and
likes it a lot as well but Pico does not
yet have the same expansive app catalog
that meta does so some fans but maybe a
few drawbacks why hasn't bite dance
launched Pico to consumers in the US yet
bidance hasn't said whether they plan to
launch in the US but certainly Tick Tock
their other company is undergoing a
formal National Security review process
and other Chinese companies in the past
that sell consumer goods have had issues
selling in the US and so there's
certainly some hurdles there but Pico
hasn't said anything specifically about
this okay so we know that customers are
open to Pico but let's talk about meta
and maybe how it is feeling about
competition in the VR headspace I mean
for starters can you tell us a little
bit about meta's VR headset Quest and
what its market share is like meta has a
couple different headsets the one that's
aimed generally at consumers it retails
for 399 dollars that's the meta Quest
too and they are clearly dominant in the
VR headset Market okay so even after
Pico is starting to gain some traction
they still hold 75 of the global market
but what the Pico data sort of shows
Pico is now up to about 15 of the global
market and they tripled their share from
the start of 2022. so Pico is gaining
some traction it's an a lot of European
markets and a lot of Asian markets where
meta might not even be available in some
of these markets or for instance in
Germany meta exited that market and
recently came back into it but Pico's
been there this whole time so Pico sort
of has the advantage there so it's more
on the global scale that these two
companies are starting to Duke it out
you mentioned that meta still has 75
percent of the global market share in
this space I mean how of sales of the
quest headset been doing lately so
metaceta in the fourth quarter sales of
the request 2 headset were actually down
we don't have exactly comparable data
from Pico because they're not a public
us company but the data firm that
provided us this data suggested that
they did think that Pico was going to
increase its headset shipments in the
fourth quarter so presumably they expect
Pico to gain even more market share in
the latest quarter as some listeners
will remember meta's metaverse platform
Horizon worlds is struggling to get
users so what does this competition mean
for the company's metaverse Ambitions
Pico actually teased that they're going
to launch their own version basically of
horizon worlds called Pico worlds which
is a similar sort of social hangout ad
if they do gain more market share and
sort of taking on more markets and they
launch this app is that going to be
something that affects meta we'll see
what has meta said about the competition
coming from Pico so Mara said that they
welcome competition and that and any
competition is going to increase how
many people are in the VR space in
general and so they see this as good for
business these two companies are already
battling over social media users they're
battling over advertisers so what is
this next stage mean for the competition
between the two companies so bite dance
owns tick tock tick tock has taken ad
dollars and user time away from meta
away from Instagram and they did well
there we'll see if they can sort of
reproduce the same effect with this new
VR headset company but you know it's
still not currently available in the US
yet so I think it's really hard to draw
conclusions before they make an entrance
on the consumer side the headsets are
available for business use in the US but
if they're trying to compete on the
consumer side with meta they're going to
need to launch their consumer headset in
the US has bite dance commented at all
about the competition between Queen Pico
and Quest bite dance did not comment for
our article and has sort of been pretty
quiet about it in general but they did
launch a consumer headset in May last
year so clearly they are making some
strides in this space and we'll see if
they say more things once the
competition gets more heated but I think
we're still in the early innings for now
and can you just give us a sense of the
differences you know in the kind of
price and characteristics that Pico has
versus Quest The Meta headset costs 399
dollars and the Pico one is not
available in the US so it's available in
terms of Euros so when you convert it
depending on what the exchange rate is
it comes out to about 450 US dollars so
they're pretty close in price which I
think is a reason that some of the
people we talked to said they're willing
to give this other one a chance and see
and then in terms of actual Hardware
some people we talked to said they like
the fit of the Pico headset better they
liked the lenses and how it was a more
comfortable fit on their head then I
also launched in October a new headset
for professionals that retails for
fifteen hundred dollars and so certainly
you know this might not be the consumer
headset of choice for people who want to
use a meta headset right now but Pico
releases their new headset meta then
comes back and releases their new
headset so clearly you know they're
duking it out over the hardware alright
that's our reporter Megan bobrowski
Megan thanks for joining us thanks for
having me and that's it for today's Tech
news briefing if you want more Tech
stories check out our website wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal thanks for listening
[Music]
thank you